[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
i'm c.a murray and i'm in the company of
pastor daniel maranda
we are both associate speakers here at
secrets unsealed and some tv and having
a fine time doing it
this is our bible question and answer
program i like this program for a number
of reasons one i like to study uh the
word of god and two i like to study the
word of god in the company of uh
people who love study the word of god
such as yourself pastor likewise
we have a a good time here we love the
lord
and uh we pray that you love the lord
and
um we promise each week to answer your
questions from the word of god if an
answer can be found there is much to
understand in the word of god the bible
tells us that spiritual things are
spiritually discerned so
before we ever attempt to answer any
questions we ask for the mind of christ
so that we can give you answers from the
word of god and not our own personal
opinion the bible says those in berea
were more noble than those in
thessalonica because after they heard
they searched for themselves so we will
give you answers from the word of god
but that does not substitute for your
own personal study of the word of god
because you need to know god for
yourself you need to know the promises
of god for yourself
if you don't study you don't even know
what promises to claim when you are
assaulted by the enemy so we will give
you answers but uh they don't substitute
for your own personal devotion and study
time with
god and with his word is that not so
pastor yes that's right we need to be
personal students of the bible amen amen
and amen
so we've got a number of questions today
and we've got one question with eight
parts
so we don't know how far we're going to
get and how many questions we will get
too but we promise you we will try to
get to every question that is sent in
the list is long and impressive but uh
there are answers and we have answers
for you from the word of god pastor if
you would lead out in prayer then we're
going to tackle some of these questions
sure let's pray dear heavenly father as
see i said we need the mind of jesus to
understand the scriptures
and help us lord answer these questions
from your word in the name of jesus we
pray amen amen and amen
this question this first one
daniel comes from uthra
sundaram
uthra sundaram i wonder if that is
of indian descent or perhaps pakistani
[Music]
could come from any number of places but
she's got an eight-part question
and so we're going to try to walk our
way through it and see how much time
this is going to go into to take up i
know you are a student of the word and
let me let me
send give you a compliment now pastor
because uh we've we've known each other
i guess maybe just a month or so
and you've become a a part of the family
so very very quickly i like the way you
atta attack the word of god your
thoroughness and and uh uh as i said to
pastor i like studying the word of god
with people who like to study the word
of god amen and it's a it's a pleasure
to to do so which is why what this
program is one of one of my favorites
but let's get to the question the first
question
um
please explain about uh the other worlds
ellen white mentioned and then these
questions all pertain to other worlds
the first one is where are they
[Music]
so let's let's take a look at that
where are the other worlds
well
we find before going to the spur of
prophecy we find a an allusion
to
the other world that exists in the book
of job that's one place and
oftentimes we go there
we see jesus where we see god here
that he's having a
a heavenly council
and we read in job chapter 1
verse 6 now there was a day when the
sons of god came to present themselves
before the lord and satan came also
among them
it doesn't tell us where they're coming
from but
they
it says that one day they presented
before the before the lord that means
that they are not always there in heaven
there are certain occasions where they
come verse 7 and the lord said unto
satan
whence comes thou where do you come from
then satan answered the lord and said
from going to and fro in the earth and
from walking up and down in it
it is as if god was asking
satan
what world are you represented yes
representing and he's saying i'm coming
from the earth
that tells me then these other sons of
god these other beings that are
mentioned here were coming from other
worlds now we don't know exactly where
these worlds are but they're all
scattered throughout the universe yes i
i
try to do a quick perusal of the spirit
of prophecy the word of god
the bible is is indefinite about where
these other worlds are
when the bible begins in the beginning
god created barashith elohim
he was talking about this world
and
the word of god is really a record of
god's interplay with this world
this world we know is the one world that
is out of harmony with the will of god
so god has can we say quarantine this
world
as far as limiting the extent the reach
of sin it's limited to this world so
this book
is god's dealing with this world because
this world has the problem
this world is out of step this world is
out of harmony so
we know there are other creations
because the bible lets us know that
but
this book is god's dealing with this
world because
let's face it we got the problem yes
and god is trying to deal with that
yeah
you wanted to say something else no i
i i'm done with that a little bit okay
so there is i uh they ask also here how
many worlds
could be there uh i've gotten that
question several times
[Music]
there is an illusion that ellen white
makes in the book christ object lessons
and when she is commenting on the
parable of the
of the lost sheep um their hundred sheep
lost
99 are not yes and then she makes an
application and she says that we are the
world that guns that went astray yes so
some people have concluded
that because of that that means that
there are 99 worlds
but
ellen white the comparison she's making
is not in relation to figures it's in
relation to the state of being lost very
true there's a quote that is in christ
triumphant
page 66
and this quote says just very short
phrase here men living in this little
atom of our world are finite
god has a numbered worlds that are
obedient to his laws and are conducted
with reference to his glory so a number
yeah kind of count them can i count them
we are
the problem the only one that fell
and and your point is well taken that
the 100 the 99
in the one that's out is is not number
it's the concern for that one little
word
what she is saying
is that man is of great value to god
amen
that he will leave
the 99 unfallen and put supreme emphasis
on this one fallen to get us back amen
uh
he bankrupted heaven
he gave all that he could all that was
necessary to get us back
and we're in the process of getting back
in fact i saw a statement the other day
ellen white says
and i'm trying to think where it was
found but she says one of the
ways that we can judge how
lost we are how far we have fallen
is how much it takes to get us back
it took the death of god himself to get
us back so
that says one that we are we've fallen
very far and two that god is willing to
pay the price to get us back amen
amen
all right are they watching us um
i've got something uh a couple things
actually this is desire of ages page 693
the world's unfallen
and the heavenly angels had watched with
intense interest as the conflict drew to
its close
satan and his confederacy of evil the
legions of apostasy watched intently
this great crisis in the work of
redemption
we know that this
7 000 year experiment
in sin is a lesson book to the universe
so they are watching intently to see
how things are going to turn out that
says to me daniel a number of things and
and i know you've got something because
you always have something so i'm sorry
but but my my my point is
they're
they're watching to see
but
there will never be any contact
between this world and unfallen worlds
this side of redemption
so i mean man can go looking for voices
in the dark or e.t
or or
that's a good thing you know other
things but there's not because sin has
been quarantined here
uh it's going to be dealt with here it
will be exterminated here we're not
going to get out go out and take our
infection
to the rest of the universe you know
even now it's interesting i was
listening just this week watching
television they're saying
with all of the
satellites and dead satellites and
communication satellites and bits and
pieces there's this ring of junk
floating around the earth
that we've got to be careful not to run
into when we send satellites up because
wherever man goes he takes his junk with
him so now we're we're we're junking up
space well god's not going to let that
go and infect other planets because
whatever we take we take our junk with
us so it's going to be quarantined here
but do they know what's going on are
they aware i think so from this text and
um desire vedic page 758 uh when christ
says it is finished that
that
quiet went throughout the universe and
unfallen worlds heard it also so we know
that they are aware of
what's going on here on planet earth
although they are not in touch with it
yeah there is a verse
here in first corinthians chapter four
verse nine that supports of course the
what you have just read because the
bible and the prophecy are in harmony oh
yes and first corinthians chapter 4
verse 9 paul says here for i think that
god hath sent set forth
the apostles last
as it were appointed to death for we are
made at spectacle and to the world and
to angels and to men so it says here
that we are spectacle in other versions
it says to the universe to the universe
yes angels to men
so being that we are at spectacle then
definitely they are watching us how
well i cannot say that
specifically they might have the gift of
prophecy or through some
revelation
but uh definitely the other walls are
are watching us
we don't know you know when we get back
to
our our state of oneness with the lord
we don't know what faculties and
abilities we will re-inherit that we
have lost
you know um
evidently there is some ability that
other worlds have to know what's going
on here when things good doing things
bad when sacrifices are made they know i
i think particularly angels uh and and
unfollow humanity are shocked by some of
the things that we do and some of the
decisions that we make and perhaps
cannot understand them because they do
not make sense uh in the in
the presence of a loving caring god who
is willing to do anything to get us back
to have people turn their back on him to
send christ and have him crucified
i don't think these actions make sense
to them
because they understand what it is to be
one with god we do not uh so a lot of
the things we do must confuse and sadden
them but i think but if they're aware
yes they are
yeah
all right um
if they're unfallen then there is no
death if there is no death won't the
world be overpopulated
that is a very good it's an interesting
series of thoughts oh yeah uh uh
we have some answers but i'll give you a
chance to take a shot at that because
it's it's interesting well i do not have
all the evidence to answer this question
i have a personal conclusion but uh
just feel free to contradict me if you
don't agree with me but i have a
personal conclusion
god gave the gift of reproduction
only to human beings
so that we could
multiply the image of god and feel the
places that satan has had left void in
heaven
so i believe i i do not believe that
they have a problem with reproduction
because when god populated the worlds he
just created as he created the angels
yes uh actually uh oftentimes we see in
the bible in the spirit of prophecy that
that these beings from other worlds are
also compared
in the likeness of angels yes so i tend
to conclude that as angels that they
don't marry and giving marriage uh
same thing with them but this is just a
personal conclusion yeah um we'll leave
that to the lord and to answer that in
him well we're in the same place when
the when the command came
be fruitful and multiply that was a
command for earth yes it was
it was not to our knowledge a universal
command it was a command to earth
uh plus
there there certainly is more freedom
more mobility in in other worlds so
the idea of overpopulation i don't think
is an issue or a problem for them when
we
um
are are redeemed
there will be no marriage there will be
no giving in marriage and so the the the
command to
repopulate to be fertile is no longer in
play correct so there's a whole new
realm of existence now uh you know i've
heard people say what about my wife and
you know well i know my wife and you
know what
we may not have all the minutia of
answers but this is one thing we do know
what
will be
is better
than what amen amen so
we don't know what heaven
is about we have nothing to compare it
to eyes not seen earth not heard
we are much more comfortable talking
about what won't be in heaven no death
no sin no eyeglasses no doctors no
lawyers you know
we know what won't be there but we don't
quite know what will be there but we do
know that it will be better amen than
what we have amen amen amen amen
and that's enough so overpopulation
won't be a problem
because we will have access to the
universe
it is not a problem because um
the only problem is that sin and and
sinners and uh are quarantined here but
outside of this universe there's there's
so much that we don't know that we don't
understand right that uh god has stored
up for us
all right when
they were created
when
they were oh i think said when were they
created
before or after adam
this is a question that that
i've seen before did god stop his
creative works
with
adam
once adam was created did god stop
creating
i looked for
and and did not find a definitive
statement by ellen white
um
suffice it to say
uh when the angels
that that left with satan
left they were replaced
so there is no definite text that i know
of or spirit of the quote that says god
stopped his creative works with with
adam suffice it to say though i think
god wants to get rid of and deal with
this sin problem that is
foremost in his mind uh at this point in
time amen yeah yeah that's true we don't
have a specific answer to this uh we do
know that and and we can see it from the
spirit prophecy that this world was
created
after the fall
uh we do know that for sure
now when the bible says in genesis
chapter 2 that god rested from his works
the word rested there
ceased shabbat that means ceased
some people have tried to conclude that
that means that he rested from creating
and
in hebrews 11 there is a verse that says
that
the works were done from the beginning
of the of the of the world
but again we don't have something very
definite and clear
in regards to this yeah the one spirit
of prophecy uh
train of thought that comes to mind and
this follows what you just said
is the fact that
genesis picks up the story in answer to
the entrance of sin in the universe sin
exists now
should we go ahead
and make man
given that this problem now
exists in heaven
well
yes
let us
pick it up in mid thought almost so sin
is in the universe it's there it's not
here yet but it's it exists right should
we
do this now uh we also find store
redemption and pitches that
adam and eve were warned that there was
a problem they were warned of this this
interloper they were warned that there
was something going on that they needed
to be aware of
that it is to stay close to one another
look out for one another because there
was this adversarial force
in the in the world that had been uh uh
kicked out of heaven so we know that the
creation of this world was after
sin uh in heaven yeah we are we're aware
of that
um
and it is my feeling that all heaven's
energies if i can use that are
concentrated on
fixing and getting rid of the sin
problem
can't give you a chapter can't give you
a verse that's my feeling that god wants
to get rid of this interloper which is
sin
ellen white says no reason can be given
for it it exists
uh and that needs to be cleaned up amen
alrighty um
do they look like humans
looking like humans is not such a great
thing
the thing is do they look like god you
know we are made in the image of god
there there is certainly
uh
a spiritual component to that and maybe
even a physical
so
you know
we don't know
i like to share ca something from early
writings
that's page
39 it's a kind of lengthy paragraph
but let me
try to read some lines from here
it says the lore has given me a view of
other worlds
wings were given me
and an angel attended me from the city
to a place that was bright and glorious
i remember that yes yes the grass of the
place was leaving green
and the birds there warbled at sweet
song
the inhabitants of the place were of all
sizes
they were noble majestic and lovely so
kind of like
the description of how adam was before
he fell
they bore the express image of jesus
and their countenances
beamed with holy joy expressive of the
freedom and happiness of the place
i asked one of them this is the
inhabitants of the other worlds i asked
one of them why they were so much more
lovely than those on the earth so we
shouldn't care much about
they reply the reply was
we have lived in a strict obedience to
the commandments of god and have not
fallen by disobedience like those on the
earth so the secret for their beauty and
their majesty is obedience
then i saw two trees
one looked much i think there is a
question about the the trees no maybe
not here but i had seen another question
if there was the tree of life in those
worlds
well she answers here then i saw two
two trees
one look
much like the tree of life in the city
the fruit of both look beautiful
but of one they could not eat
so
and she goes on to describe that she saw
enoch over there and
but
this is the closest description we read
in spirit prophecy that they were more
majestic yeah they resembled the express
image of jesus and they also had the
test of eat or or not eat right in that
same store redemption of course i don't
remember the page off hand but ellen
white says her vision of
of seeing satan
she says he was sitting and evidently
this this form is pretty utilitarian
because
satan that she saw had this form she
says his frame was large
she she describes his forehead receding
from just above the eyes his skin
hanging loosely about his his uh
his his frame he had given so long to to
sin
she says he bore the marks of because he
is a fallen angel but she says she also
saw what evil had done
over the centuries how uh he had
declined she says he had this sly smile
on his face his head was resting in his
hands and
she said he gets that kind of side smile
whenever he's about to get a christian
and and get him in his clutches uh so um
evidently the the angelic host has this
general form
um likeness
general likeness is is perhaps a better
term um plus wings i you know i think
i'd like to get wings i like that idea i
like to have wings you know that kind of
thing
but she saw him and uh he had he had
certainly human characteristics he was
much larger uh in frame
than humans but uh it was a hideous site
it was not something that she wanted to
see that she liked seeing
and i suspect frightened a little bit
but we we have an idea from that and
from again both of these in early
writing yeah and that doesn't mean that
um
here it says that
if he had a form
well if they looked like human if they
were humans well it doesn't mean having
a form of human doesn't mean that uh
necessarily we are humans
like god ellen wise saw
jesus in and
and he's and she speaks about god and
god has a form
and jesus has a form
he has a head
arms fingers but way much perfect
than
ourselves
yeah so we are all created in the image
and likeness of god
and
and definitely we are all
beings
created perfect
[Music]
and the last question i guess and and
this is one question eight parts have
taken up most of this time
uh
all when it is written that all eyes are
going to see jesus return
are the other worlds going to watch this
as well
well i think for what we have just
mentioned if they can watch what is
going on here so no doubt that they will
also
uh perhaps
be aware at least of of that great event
yes
this
reclaiming of the lost planet
is an event of cosmic significance right
and as such i would
think
that the cosmos is going to be involved
we know that they are aware of the the
salient features of the salvation
experience here on planet earth
when christ went to the cross
the universe knew about that when christ
comes to reclaim his own
i suspect the universe will know about
that
it will be such a joyous event as he
presents his church to his father it
will be of universal consequence it is
of universal interest and will be
celebrated
universally amen uh and we praise we
praise god for that yeah the world the
universe is waiting for for us to get
right with god and forgot to end this
thing amen god is suffering too we think
so much about our suffering
but god is suffering too because heaven
will not be complete while this this
sin experience is still here it's got to
be cleaned up it will be cleaned up and
if you read the last
oh several chapters of great controversy
you see what a joy
is going to go through the universe she
talks about the the universe will again
be at harmony it will be at peace
everything will be functioning as it
should so we are out of step now and the
day that we get back in line back in
step will be a day of universal
celebration amen and praise to god and
i'm i'm looking forward to it what about
yourself yes certainly indeed
we praise the lord so utra you gave us
eight interesting questions
and we we appreciate that good questions
uh good good questions god is good and
um we want to encourage you to
first of all continue your study of the
word of god always study for yourself
study to show that self-approved and
send in questions and if you have
issues and questions we'll try to do our
best to answer them you see the contact
information there at the bottom of the
screen again until we see you next time
god bless we'll see you again soon
[Music]
you